[Music]
this may look like a neatly arranged
stack of numbers but it's actually a
mathematical treasure trove Indian
mathematicians called it the staircase
of Mount Meru in Iran it's the Khayyam
triangle and in China it's Yong ways
triangle to much of the Western world
it's known as Pascal's triangle after
French mathematician Blaise Pascal which
seems a bit unfair since he was clearly
late to the party
but he still had a lot to contribute so
what is it about this that has so
intrigued mathematicians the world over
in short it's full of patterns and
secrets first and foremost there's the
pattern that generates it start with one
and imagine invisible zeros on either
side of it add them together in pairs
and you'll generate the next row now do
that again and again keep going and
you'll wind up with something like this
the really Pascal's triangle goes on
infinitely now each row corresponds to
what's called the coefficients of a
binomial expansion of the form X plus y
raised to the N where n is the number of
the row and we start counting from 0 so
if you make n equal 2 and expand it you
get x squared plus 2xy plus y squared
the coefficients or numbers in front of
the variables are the same as the
numbers in that row of Pascal's triangle
you'll see the same thing with N equals
3 which expands to this so the triangle
is a quick and easy way to look up all
of these coefficients but there's much
more for example add up the numbers in
each row and you'll get successive
powers of 2 or in a given row treat each
number as part of a decimal expansion in
other words Row 2 is 1 times 1 plus 2
times 10 plus 1 times 100 you get 121
which is 11 squared and take a look at
what happens when you do the same thing
to row 6 it adds up to 1 million 770
1561 which is 11 to the 6 and so on
there are also geometric applications
look at the diagonals the first two
aren't very interesting all ones and
then the positive integers also known as
natural numbers but the numbers in the
next diagonal are called the triangular
numbers because if you take that many
dots you can stack them into equilateral
triangles the next diagonal has the
tetrahedral numbers because similarly
you can stack that many spheres into
tetrahedra or how about this shade in
all of the odd numbers it doesn't look
like much when the triangles small but
if you add thousands of rows you get a
fractal known as your Pinsky's triangle
this triangle isn't just a mathematical
work of art it's also quite useful
especially when it comes to probability
and calculations in the domain of
combinatorics say you want to have five
children and would like to know the
probability of having your dream family
of three girls and two boys in the
binomial expansion that corresponds to
girl plus boy to the fifth power so we
look at the row 5 where the first number
corresponds to 5 girls and the last
corresponds to 5 boys the third number
is what we're looking for 10 out of the
sum of all the possibilities in the row
so 10 over 32 or 31 point to 5% or if
you're randomly picking a 5 player
basketball team out of a group of 12
friends how many possible groups of 5
are there in combinatoric terms this
problem would be phrased as 12 choose 5
and could be calculated with this
formula or you could just look at the
sixth element of row 12 on the triangle
and get your answer the patterns in
Pascal's triangle are a testament to the
elegantly interwoven fabric of
mathematics and it's still revealing
fresh secrets to this day for example
mathematicians recently discovered a way
to expand it to these kinds of
polynomials
what might we find next well that's up
to you
[Music]